hey leute was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir
haben schon ganz schön später für 24 uhr
ich habe mir so eine kleine aufgabe
gesetzt und zwar dachte ich mir in der
korona zeit als sind so viele leute
dafür dass schüler ihr seid einfach den
ganzen tag nur zu hause und da dachte
ich mir ich muss mal ein experiment
wagen scheiße jetzt hab ich gar kein
euro hier oder
ich habe eigentlich heute morgen noch
dran gedacht das ist cool wäre ich dann
so ein euro rein halte aber jetzt habe
ich einfach kein euro gehabt also musste
das jetzt so machen wir mehr als 50 cent
20 16 10 und moment noch mal 20 cent
also insgesamt haben wir hier ein euro
ja das ist sozusagen mein star und so
habe ich mir folgendes überlegt er kennt
es ja ihr seid auf youtube die ganze
zeit kommen irgendwelche online coaches
oder sowie wollen euch irgendwas an
drehen damit wirst du recht hast du noch
reicher damen die es zu einem reichen
was zu 90 prozent halten computer
bullshit ist das ist ja ganz klar aber
ich habe mir gedacht das internet das
bietet so viele möglichkeiten
es muss doch die möglichkeit geben so
wie es diese ganzen online coaches
predigen das waren irgendwie auf welche
art und weise auch immer ich habe schon
ein paar pläne aufgestellt aber dass man
irgendwie mit 0 startkapital sein geld
im internet verdienen kann nebenbei
mitarbeit natürlich und deswegen startet
heute dieses video experiment ich möchte
mit dem ein euro anfangen und in ich hab
so drei folgen angesetzt also es wäre
schön wenn ich dann innerhalb dieser
drei folgen auf 1000 euro kamen mit
irgendwelchen dubiosen sachen also sie
sollten schon egal sein aber irgendwas
was ich halt im internet mache von zu
hause aus ganz klar und ich denke das
kann wirklich interessant werden vor
allem für die jüngeren von euch die sich
immer denken was mache ich gehe ich
zeitungen austragen oder nicht hat euch
das video an und vielleicht klappt's ja
ich bin mal gespannt also ich denke dass
wir das irgendwie hinbekommen werd ich
will gar nicht zu viel aber wir legen
würde ich sagen direktwahl los ich habe
noch was für euch und zwar entsteht das
heutige video mit freundlicher
unterstützung von sonko wenn jetzt neue
epos draußen das sind die liberty r2 pro
und die packen wir jetzt mal aus die
könnte ich dann eigentlich verkaufen
dann hab ich schon mal 100 euro
nein das ist es gegen die spielregeln
schade eigentlich ich habe davon nämlich
noch zwei weiteren aber wenn ihr lust
habt könnt ihr die gebunden
so ganz neu ist ein perfekt zu den
kopfhörern wir haben hier für 129 euro
und 99 in deutschland die liberty er
toubro sie verfügen über noise
cancelling du kannst damit deinen hirai
die personalisierten sound erstellen
wenn die dinger voll aufgeladen sind
halten sie sieben stunden mit case sogar
26 schon am stück und wir machen die
kurz mal auf das macht man so dann sieht
das so aus er hat und die aus dem
schaufenster hier drin liegt auf jeden
fall sehr hochwertig dann haben wir hier
das case ich weiß schon dass kann man
hier so wunderbar aufschieben dann legt
man die kopfhörer hier rein
wir haben hier noch ein ladekabel dabei
und beschreibung achso und ganz wichtige
können zehn hier werden neun
verschiedene ihr tipps mitgeliefert so
dass die halt safe jedem passen müssen
erster eindruck sehr gut jetzt müssen
wir mal schauen was sie können ich bin
gespannt das ist folter flashback ich
habe ja früher einmal so kopfhörer
getestet und so ok ich merke jetzt schon
das neue scans ling ist aktiv meine
stimme höre ich persönlich gerade noch
sehr leise let's go wir hatten mal ein
los
so
leute merken dass sorgen doch kloster
von neo neo ist ein künstler habe ich
früher sehr gerne gehört vor allem
diesen song der hatten damit geworden
also der weiß wirklich wie musik
funktioniert und support auch diese
marke
deswegen gibt es in vier verschiedenen
farben check die beschreibungen erster
linie in der bibel schreiben wir machen
weiter mit dem video
ich muss so dringend auch wieder zum
friseur leute was geht wir befinden uns
hier in meinem neuen polo ist noch
nichts drin deswegen lohnt das auch
nicht zu zeigen aber hier starke jetzt
mein plan und zwar ist es ja ein
bisschen schwierig einfach irgendwie mir
zur umfragen oder so an geld zu kommen
aber nirgendwo mit muss sich auf staaten
deswegen habe ich bei ihnen seiner
youtube werbung die seite empfohlen de
gefunden und da habe ich jetzt bei
sonnen paar tests wird gemacht und habe
jetzt schon elf euro verdient dafür habe
ich auch nicht mehr lange gebraucht das
war ungefähr so eine dreiviertelstunde
aber als anfänger und christ auch
richtig viel vorgeschlagen hat damit du
da so bleibt ist ja klar die wollen
nicht locken
ich habe euch das hier mal mitgefilmt
insgesamt habe ich drei aufträge gemacht
bei der zum beispiel muss ich mich bei
lotto irgendwie anmelden und da habe ich
dann selbst euro verdient und insgesamt
bin ich sogar am ende auf 16 euro nicht
wie gleich bei mir gesagt älteren
gekommen also das ganz wichtig diese
werden allerdings nicht behalten sondern
wieder reinvestieren und zwar im
folgendes geniales geschäftskonzept
entwickelt von mir zur hälfte zumindest
ich habe in so einem amerikanischen
videos einen typen gesehen der hat das
ähnlich gemacht und zwar hat er ne app
entdeckt mit der man ganz einfach solo
größte sein kann ohne großen aufwand da
sind alle vorlagen schon drin und da
dachte ich mir das klingt interessant
das kann ich auch und diese logos möchte
ich dann einfach nur an möglichst viele
leute verkaufen weil du hast halt
wirklich nur maximal fünf minuten
aufwand pro logo und wenn ich möglichst
viele kunden erreichen werde ich dadurch
sicherlich gutes geld verdienen können
in möglichst kurzer zeit dann habe ich
mir neuen instagram account erstellt mit
dem genialen namen jeep logo design und
dort schon mal drei muster hochgeladen
die ich selber mit der app erstellt habe
um kunden zu generieren um an möglichst
viele leute zu kommen wollte ich die 16
euro in promotion investieren um leute
auf meine seite zu locken damit in das
vorgeschlagen wird und das habe ich dann
heute aufgemacht nebenbei habe ich mich
mit der gleichen idee noch bei 4
angemeldet und mit zwei weiteren ideen
und zwar einmal mit dem design von
youtube thumbnails und auch noch mit
photoshop skills dass ich leuten halt
sachen ausschneidet für fünf euro es
gibt nur leider mittlerweile viel zu
viele angebote auf weswegen ich kann ich
jetzt schon sagen absolut gar nichts
damit verdient habt aber der logo
verkauf über instagram
hat zumindest am anfang so dachte ich
eigentlich ziemlich gut angefangen leute
das okay ich habe mich mal werbung
gestellt ich habe einfach meinen leuten
gefolgt und jetzt habe ich schon meine
erste anfrage huhu fünf euro ich hoffe
dass wir etwas 5 dollar
so ein hund sunny so klar ich habe zu
sehen das gute am menschen geglaubt und
zwar mein erster kunde man muss sagen
die geschäftig der ist doch gut oder ich
komme da hat übrigens aus der dusche
deswegen habe ich auch noch ein
bademantel an
auf jeden fall ihr könnt den
chartverlauf mit dem typen sehen
ich habe ihm ein logo gemacht so sah das
aus oder so sieht das aus ich habe extra
noch so leicht sample darüber
geschrieben damit er es nicht einfach
abziehen und mich dann blockiert und was
hat er gemacht er schreibt mir doch bis
es perfekt hab ich gefragt hast du
paypal also ja ich habe paypal dann was
ist ein paypal ich so dass und da er so
wie teuer ich fünf dollar normalpreis
vielleicht kannst du noch ein bisschen
trinker geben er so okay geben mir eine
sekunde ich warte ich guck 20 minuten
später darauf nichts bekommen ich gehe
auf sein profil der hat mich einfach
blockiert man aber davon lasse ich mich
jetzt gar nicht aus der ruhe bringen ich
werde jetzt diesen beitrag ihr könnt ihr
hier meinem profil sehen im visa hier
kamen ganz gut an dieses logo das werde
ich jetzt hervorheben also bauten mit
bisschen geld mit dem geld was ich
verdient habe
dann hoffe ich mal dass ich weitere
anfragen kriege und dann auch wirklich
langsam geld verdienen ich könnte jetzt
schon 67 dollar haben durch den typen
aber nein er hat mich blockiert das logo
war doch wirklich gut oder okay leute
ihr könnt sehen ausstehende
genehmigungen ich habe jetzt hier auf
werbung gestaltet für einen tag ich
hoffe das klappt ich werde es noch ein
paar weiteren leuten folgen und dann ist
mein geschäftskonzept perfekt ich hoffe
einfach dass funktioniert man das wäre
so wichtig sonst ist eigentlich dieses
projekt gescheitert ich habe da alles
rein gestellt meine ganze hoffnung wir
werden uns später wieder sehen leute was
geht da ich glaube ich muss mich mal
hinsetzen und ich hab mir dass meine
haare rasiert erst dann ein bisschen
deswegen nicht jetzt
ich glaube ich jetzt besser mal die kapo
es ist auf jeden fall der menge zeit
vergangen um genau zu sein zwei tage ich
habe vorgestern die promotion erstellt
und seitdem habe ich nicht glaube ich
gar nicht mehr gemeldet
ich habe aber viel an dem projekt
weitergearbeitet ohne ist jetzt
irgendwie vor der kamera zu zeigen vor
allem gestern wirklich bestimmt 56
stunden und das hat sich auch einiges
getan mit der promotion sollten ja
eigentlich ich glaube 8300 personen
erreicht werden ich habe 16 euro darauf
geballert wichtig für mich war auch dass
weltweit leute erreicht werden weil ich
habe sie auf englisch gemacht einfach um
mehr leute erreichen zu können
dann habe ich noch so ein paar text
hinzugefügt wie zum beispiel grafiken
zielgruppe mindestens 18 jahre
alt und nach ungefähr der hälfte der
zeit hatte sich wirklich niemand bei mir
gemeldet aber es sind auch nur irgendwie
drei leute auf meinem profil gegangen
durch diese promotion dann habe ich
gedacht hey [ __ ] diese acht euro spaß
sie es lieber dann habe ich das beendet
wieder rausgenommen und habe einfach
überall kommentiert wo leute ganz kurz
und zwar verstehen schon ewig bei einer
million und 8000 abonnenten ungefährlich
sie heute mal über 70 prozent
mittlerweile von euch die manchmal die
videos haben den kanal nicht abonniert
das ist mega schade ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ihr die videos geschaut dann
macht das super gerne jetzt jetzt beim
dritten und jeden der nur irgendwie
meine story gesehen hat oder mein
beitrag gelegt hat mir gefolgt ist was
auch immer
dem habe ich den gleichen texte
schrieben hey ich mache logo für fünf
dollar wird zu haben
du kannst danach bezahlen und so weiter
das war alles gestern und ich habe
wirklich ein paar logos die seit ich
glaube vier stück insgesamt
und wir sind jetzt aktuell bei einem
paypal guthaben von 31 eur 65 das
problem ist ich habe da bestimmt acht
stunden rein investiert weswegen wir
einen stundenlohn von ungefähr vier euro
haben naja immerhin durch noch einmal
ganz kurz zur erklärung wie sich der
betrag zusammen setzt damit das auch
jeder glaubt und verstehen kann meine
haare gehen gar nicht klar deswegen habe
ich mal wieder eine mütze auf jeden fall
hatte ich den ein euro startkapital
dann habe ich 16 euro dazuverdienen
landen wir bei 17 euro dann habe ich von
dem 17 eur 8 dollar in promotion
investiert dollar ist bisschen weniger
wert als euro anlage ich wieder bei
ungefähr zehn euro dann habe ich aber
viel losverkauf für jeweils fünf dollar
außer einer der hat mir sogar acht
dollar überwiesen sehr korrekt immer
dazu geschrieben ich würde mich über den
kleinen tipp freuen also bisher ein
trinker die musste der erde mit paypal
bezahlen und auf mein paypal liegen
jetzt halt einleitung 65 die ich in den
letzten drei tagen verdient haben viel
ich weiß
aber ich muss sagen ich habe das
wirklich so viel leichter vorgestellt
ich hatte einfach im gefühl diese idee
ist zu krass dass wir zeit funktionieren
einfach auch weil es so günstig ist bei
fire kostenlos mindestens irgendwie man
neun bis 14 30 euro und bei mir ich muss
sagen ich bin auch eigentlich immer noch
megafon dieser idee überzeugt ich habe
halt nur nicht die richtigen leute
herein vor allem auch nicht mit der
promotion das ging am sonntag halten
wenn man da 8000 richtige leute erreicht
glaube ich schon dass da 10 20 mit dabei
sind die sich dann seinem logo
beschaffen bei mir für fünf dollar wenn
ihr tipps habt wie ich das bei instagram
vielleicht optimieren kann dass ich da
bessere leute erreiche für den nächsten
part ich habe hier wirklich leichter
vorgestellt werden mit 31 eur 65 das ist
ein anfang es ist jetzt nicht die welt
aber es ist immerhin ein anfang
und darauf kann man aufbauen wenn ihr
noch ideen habt was ich noch machen kann
für die nächsten parks also ich hätte es
gerne 3 platz durch weil ich da noch was
wir sondern es mit dem geld vorhaben
dann schreiben sie mir gerne in den
kommentaren ich hoffe aber passieren hat
es euch trotzdem unterhalten und wir
sehen uns dann am sonntag wieder da
gibt's neues interessantes video dann
wirst du schon abonniert super g in den
kanal das war's von mir
haut rein